um we have now as predicted
another new
goal post another new deadline
from my pillow ceo and founder mike
lindell
we call him mike pillow the latest is
the tuesday or the wednesday
before thanksgiving so last month our
friend zach petrizo from salon
wrote this article mike lindell moves
the reinstatement goal posts again
now trump will be back by thanksgiving
that is locked in stone everybody says
my pillow guy despite no evidence no
paperwork and no legal case
pillow executive turned election truther
lindell has revised his prediction yet
again
as to when the u.s supreme court will
hear his undisclosed legal argument that
the 2020 election should be overturned
um lindell made an excited announcement
that his mysterious legal team has
fast-tracked internal research claiming
that his thus far imaginary supreme
court case is now ahead of schedule this
is last month remember this is the big
announcement everyone he said to steve
bannon i made a promise to this country
that with all the evidence i have that
we would get it to the supreme court and
i predicted they would vote 9-0 to look
at the evidence he then asserted that
before thanksgiving which falls on
november 25 the court will have heard
his case or now
he he admits originally i hoped for
august and september i asked all the
lawyers yesterday we're taking this to
the supreme court before thanksgiving
okay
there is now a new clip of pillow
talking to mike lindell just a few days
ago
it's now
still before thanksgiving
but it's only now going to be
that an attorney general will be
supporting this going to the supreme
court by thanksgiving so it's another
backtracking first it was by
thanksgiving the supreme court will have
voted to take the case and hear the
evidence now it's i'll have an ag
supporting me
by
i guess it's the tuesday or the
wednesday before thanksgiving take a
listen to this tuesday
before thanksgiving you're gonna have an
ag that's prepared to go you have the
lawsuit filed and then you're gonna
start that evening or the next day a
marathon of information on frank's
speech
wednesday night wednesday night before
thanksgiving tuesday
isn't it is this sad or is it funny or
is it stupid or or is it all of the
above remember
after
the november of 2020 it's a year ago
guys it's a year ago at this point it'll
be more than a year by the time
thanksgiving comes around
if we survive long enough to make it to
thanksgiving uh first it was guys
between today when it was november
between today november 8th i think it
was when the media called it for joe
biden between today november 8th and
december 14th the day that the electors
certify in each state
this is going to be flipped to trump or
prompt as some of them would say
uh didn't happen okay
between today december 14th and january
6th when congress counts the votes this
is going to be flipped to trump they're
going to stop the counting on january
6th we know how that turned out
uh riotous coup insurrection attempt in
washington dc 400 people arrested
roughly 300 400 something like that okay
it didn't go well fine between january 7
and january was it 20th or 21st that was
the um that was inauguration day now i
actually don't remember let me look at
my january calendar
it was the
20th okay
between
the riot and inauguration day it's gonna
go to biden
didn't happen okay well then they
started to fork they some said all right
it's going to be between january 20th
and march or april others said we
succeeded
it's not the real joe biden that became
president it's
the real job biden's dead
it started to get even crazier and then
you know april became early summer and
then it became fourth of july and then
it became august and then it became the
fall and now it's going to be
thanksgiving but not really thanksgiving
there will be support from the attorney
general for the supreme court case and
the supreme court case will come at some
point thereafter
what i said in november is expect this
to keep going and going and going until
at a certain point it becomes listen
guys the way to really do this
is going to be by winning the midterms
if we win the midterms then we'll put
donald trump back in
and then even if they win the midterms
trump's not coming back in so then it'll
be well now that we've won the midterms
let's just elect donald trump in 2024
that's the sequence and there's going to
be grifting
and trying to grab cash throughout the
entire thing candidates trying to grab
cash by saying give me money to win to
then bring trump back or to finally
they'll speak in coded language to
really deal with the the stolen election
once and for all but eventually it's
just going to be oh the way to get trump
back in is to elect him in 2024 which we
have been saying all along we knew all
along that that would be the case so no
surprise here mike pillow as pathetic as
ever